le corps de Karine esquivillon a été
retrouvé celui-ci était enterré dans un
bois à environ une dizaine de kilomètres
de son domicile à mâcher en Vendée c'est
son époux Michel pial qui est passé aux
aveux dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
et qui a ensuite guidé les gendarmes de
la section de recherche de Nantes vers
le corps d'après Le Parisien le
misanthose a affirmé aux enquêteurs que
la mort de sa femme serait un accident
une balle serait parti de façon
involontaire alors qu'il était en train
de nettoyer son arme à feu car il
esquivillon maire de 5 enfants avait
mystérieusement disparu le 27 mars et
depuis le début de l'affaire Michel pial
avait toujours assuré que son épouse
était parti volontairement dans le
Sud-Ouest pour se ressourcer elle a
toujours voulu aller vivre dans le sud
entre Bordeaux et Toulouse avait-il même
affirmé lors d'une rencontre avec le
Figaro pourtant certains éléments de son
parcours de vie interrogés il est décrit
comme une personne dangereuse qui use de
faux documents de fausses cartes bleues
et de checker voler élégant de fausses
rentrée d'argent pour escroquer ceux qui
le côtoient avaient indiqué son père
mais aussi les parents de la disp son
ex-femme la notamment accusé d'abandon
de famille et de non-paiement d'une
pension alimentaire fait pour lesquelles
Michel pial a été condamné elle le
décrit comme quelqu'un présentant un
comportement mythomaniaque inventant des
scénarios rocamboles pour annoncer des
rentrées d'argent imaginaires Michel
pial lui aurait par exemple fait croire
avoir touché 26 millions puis 4
milliards de francs dans la vente à IBM
d'une entreprise de bornes interactive
l'argent n'arrivant pas le couple a dû
s'inscrire au resto du coeur puis à du
dilapider un héritage familial de la
compagne il lui dévoile alors qu'il est
tireur d'élite dans les services
spéciaux pour justifier la raison de
tous leurs mots mais tout cela était
faux comme laboura le père de Michel
pial à sa compagne l'homme de 51 ans va
désormais être déféré ce vendredi devant
les juges d'instruction en charge du
dossier Karine esquive Lyon dans le
cadre de l'information judiciaire
ouverte pour enlèvement et séquestration
ainsi que moi
[Musique]